you see a hot chick he goes up I found
out that it goes up if you're around
weapons if you're near that's an advice
for keeping lots of weapons I suppose in
your house and touching them regularly
what are the biggest contributors mainly
the bad sleep I think is very very
impactful and a lot of people are in a
perpetually trying to compensate state
for their poor sleep with over
consumption of stimulants caffeine Etc
to make up for Sleep which the half-life
of these is bleeding into the night when
you're trying to get to sleep and it's
just this vicious circle of a disaster
that results in low hormone output and
then there's the diets have been pretty
bad in recent years in terms of like
quality and choice of foods you know
people are going to stuff that's not
even food